Speaker of the House Paul Ryan announced
today he won't be running for
re-election once regarded as a rising
star in Republican politics he's been
speaker for almost three years and he
leaves behind a party in shambles
Republicans are now on track to lose the
house this fall for the first time in 10
years who knows if they will but they're
close Ryan deserves a lot of the blame
for that
Donald Trump won unexpectedly in 2016 by
vowing to secure the borders and focus
on this country's vanishing middle class
Ryan acted like none of that ever
happened he never liked Trump personally
and that's of course fine but he ignored
voters and that's not fine Ryan
considered democracy an inconvenience he
delivered a massive corporate tax cut
that a few people voted for he blocked a
meaningful border security that a lot of
people wanted most Republicans don't
agree with Paul Ryan so no wonder the
party is collapsing now Ryan is fleeing
the scene of the crime he's only 48 and
will soon be rich like his tiny donor
base which is also his main constituency
have fun the rest of us are still stuck
here